today we're talking about database
auditing multi-cloud fluency and
enhanced customer experience management
i'm mark and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
if you manage sensitive data in your
mysql database you might be obligated to
record and monitor user database
activity especially if you work in a
regulated industry
cloud sql for mysql has developed a new
audit plugin called the cloud sql for
mysql audit plugin that offers
enterprise grade database auditing to
help you maintain a strong compliant
security posture you can now define
audit rules that govern which database
activity is recorded
as it footprints get more complex you
can expect to see a broader range of
cloud provider requirements showing up
where you work and interview ready or
not multi-cloud is happening
and while multi-cloud fluency is a huge
opportunity for an engineer how do you
make the most of your time and bandwidth
to meet that goal
check out the blog for thoughts on
gaining multi-cloud fluency and where to
focus
sprinkler the unified customer
experience management platform for
modern enterprises has partnered with
google cloud to accelerate its go to
market strategy and grow awareness among
our joint customers to learn more about
this exciting partnership and the
challenges we jointly solve for
customers check out the recent
conversation between google cloud's vp
of marketing sarah kennedy and
sprinkler's chief experience officer
grad khan or read the press release on
the partnership
the cloud can be complicated which is
why we've been working on helping google
cloud users with activeassist it's a
portfolio of tools to help you optimize
your cloud usage and configuration with
recommendations around cost performance
security and even sustainability check
out the new product page that helps
break down which solutions you can get
started with
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud